Tatort Deutschland präsentiert den
dunklen Januar jeden Tag ein neuer
Kriminalfall ein tägliches Tatort
Deutschlands Spezial mein Name ist scary
und ich wünsche euch eine spannende
Kredite
hallo ich bin Natalie Strauß und ich
begrüße euch zu unseren Tatort
Deutschland Spezial einen Monat lang
präsentiert euch Bild die
spektakulärsten Kriminalfälle der
Menschheitsgeschichte True Crime von der
Antike bis zur Gegenwart
Geld macht Sex und ein bis heute
ungeklärter Mordfall in der heutigen
Folge nehmen wir euch mit ins jungen
Nachkriegsdeutschland wo Ende der 50er
Jahre der Mord an der Prostituierten
Rosemarie nedrebit für ein handfesten
Skandal und eine zitternde Elite sorgt
denn Rosemarie nutribitt verkehrt in den
höchsten Kreisen und die höchsten Kreise
verkehren mit ihr und auch heute bin ich
nicht allein im Studio zusammen mit
Sprecher und Moderator Mirko Kasimir
rollig den Fall auf hey Mirko hallo
Natalie schön dich zu sehen und liebe
Grüße auch in unsere Podcast Hörerinnen
und Hörer schön dass ihr dabei seid der
Mordfall Rosemarie wird hat Deutschland
den Atem gehalten eine Prostituierte
stirbt und die Nation Rätsel wäre der
Täter ist denn in den Fokus geraten auch
die einflussreichsten Männer der
Republik es ist der erste november 1957
in der feinen Frankfurter Stiftstraße
wird die 24-Jährige Edelprostituierte
Rosemarie Nitribitt erwürgt in ihrer
Wohnung aufgefunden
als Täter kommt nichts irgendwer in
Frage sondern die Mächtigen der noch
jungen Republik Banker Wirtschaftsbosse
Prominente und Politiker und genau das
macht den Fall so spannend vor allem
damals im spießbürgerlichen Deutschland
in den 1950er Jahren ist Prostitution
verpönt was zählt ist Anstand
Bürgerlichkeit und Familie bezahlte Sex
hat in dieser Welt nichts zu suchen
sowas macht man nicht und die mächtigen
doch wohl auch nicht oder doch hinter
der biederin und sauberen Fassade geht
es sehr freizügig zu die
Edelprostituierte Rosemarie niedrig ist
damals in der Frankfurter promis-szene
statt bekannt und sehr gut im Geschäft
der Mord an ihr ist der erste große
Skandal die die noch junge Republik
gierig aufsaugt
Mirko bevor wir jetzt aber genauer auf
den Mordfall zu sprechen kommen lasst
uns doch noch mal Rosemarie genau
erkennen lernen man kann sagen sie hatte
nämlich keine einfache Kindheit sie war
geprägt von Unsicherheiten und einer
sehr kaputten Familie das kann man wohl
sagen Natalie Rosemarie Nitribitt kommt
1933 in Düsseldorf zur Welt als
uneheliches Kind damals ein stegmar zu
ihrem Vater hat sie keinen Kontakt sie
wächst mit ihren Halbschwestern bei der
Mutter in Ratingen auf die Verhältnisse
sind
ärmlich und die Mutter Gerät regelmäßig
mit dem Gesetz in Konflikt sie muss
mehrfach ins Gefängnis als Folge
verliert sie das Sorgerecht für ihre
Kinder die kleine Rosemarie wird
mehrfach ins Kinderheim eingewiesen
bricht aber immer wieder aus siegelt als
schwer erziehbar doch dann der
Lichtblick
1939 nimmt eine Pflegefamilie aus
Rheinland-Pfalz Rosemarie auf das hätte
damals für Rosemarie netrebit der
Einstieg in den bürgerliches Leben
werden aber es kommt alles anders
nachdem ihr etwas Furchtbares angetan
wird und das ist wirklich furchtbar denn
als Rosemarie 11 Jahre alt ist wird sie
von einem jungen Mann aus ihrer
Nachbarschaft vergewaltigt besonders
grausam daran die Menschen im Dorf
kennen den Täter schützen ihn aber und
so wird er nie zur Rechenschaft gezogen
ob dieses Verbrechen nun Rosemaries
Einstieg in die Prostitution befördert
hat das wissen wir nicht aber es ist
davon auszugehen denn nach der
Vergewaltigung zieht Rosemarie sich von
ihrem Umfeld zurück und im Alter von
gerade einmal 13 Jahren mehr noch Kind
als Teenager kommt Rosemarie erstmals in
Kontakt mit dem Rotlicht
sie beginnt damit ihren Körper zu
verkaufen und merkt wie einträglich
dieses Geschäft ist ihre ersten Kunden
sind amerikanische und französische
Soldaten die nach Ende des Zweiten
Weltkriegs in Deutschland stationiert
sind bereits im Alter von 14 Jahren hat
Rosemarie Nitribitt ihre erste
Abtreibung hinter sich und später dann
als junge Erwachsene wird aus der
gelegenheitshure eine professionelle
Prostituierte eine schillernde Figur in
Frankfurts Nachtleben ihr Spezialgebiet
reiche Kunden und von denen gibt es in
Frankfurt eine ganze Menge
vermutlich sah rosemariete wird keine
andere Wahl als als Prostituierte zu
arbeiten immerhin war sie ganz früher
auf sich allein gestellt sie hatte
keinen Schutz von Familie keinen
stabiles soziales Umfeld ja und mit der
Prostitution ließ sich schnell viel Geld
verdienen und das hat sie verstanden und
ich muss ehrlich sagen ich finde es
sogar erstaunlich insbesondere für
bisschen Zeit wie selbstbestimmt und
zielgerichtet mutig vor allem Rosemarie
ihren Weg als Sexarbeiterin gegangen ist
ich meine wir müssen uns noch mal vor
Augen rufen wir sprechen hier über die
1950er Jahre die Welt ist eine ganz
andere als die die wir heute kennen
Toleranz hat in dieser Gesellschaft
überhaupt Null Platz und dann kommt da
diese junge blonde hübsche Frauen die
Ecke ja sie ist sauber und er Dreck
gekleidet weiß ganz genau was sie will
und sie holt es sich auch
Rosemarie die tribit damals auch bekannt
unter ihrem tarnamen Rebecca lebt in der
Stiftstraße einer der nobelsten Adressen
Frankfurt
unvorstellbar für damalige Verhältnisse
Rosemarie geht aktiv auf Männer zu
spricht sie an und fragt sie ob sie Sex
wollen das ist unerhört aber sehr
erfolgreich und je länger sie im
Geschäft ist desto mehr Geld steht dir
zur Verfügung und desto pompöser wird ja
auftritt
sie überlegt sich wie komme ich an
Männer mit Geld
Rosemarie nitribitts Antwort sie nimmt
Benimm Stunden sie lernt wie sie sich in
der Welt der High Society zu benehmen
hat ihr Geschäft ist unfassbar lukrativ
sie hat bis zu neun freier am Tag und
die machen sie zu einer reichen Frau
Rosemarie kauft sich eines der
wichtigsten Statussymbole der
Nachkriegszeit ein Auto einen teuren und
schicken schwarzen Mercedes 190 SL
mit diesem Gefährt fällt sie auf
sie soll um die 80.000 Bar im Jahr
verdient haben das sind zum Vergleich
vom Wert her auf unsere heutige Zeit
umgerechnet um die 500.000 Euro das ist
der Wahnsinn sie hat keinen Zuhälter dem
sie irgendwie Geld abgeben muss sie
zahlt keine Steuern und gehört damals
also zu den absoluten Topverdienern
genauso wie ihre Kunden lass uns mal
über ihre Kunden sprechen
Rosemarie Nitribitt hat geschafft was
sie wollte
Deutschlands Elite geht Ende der 1950er
Jahre bei ihr ein und aus ihre Wohnung
ist eine wohlbekannte Adresse bei dem
prominenten und Mächtigen der ideale
Platz für diskrete erotische Treffen mit
einer extrovertierten fröhlichen und
dank des Benehmen Unterrichts eleganten
Jungfrau tja und alle sind im Charme der
Rosemarie die tribit erlegen Playboy
unter Sachs sein Bruder Ernst der
industrielle Harald Quandt Krups Sohn
Harald von Bohlen und Halbach sie
verkehren nicht nur mit der nit sie
machen ihr zum schnell auch teure
Geschenke und schicken ihr Liebesbriefe
in einem dieser Briefe bezeichnet Harald
von Bohlen und Halbach Rosemaries Brüste
als Mondschein blasse blütenhügel
die Geschäfte laufen gut für Rosemarie
sie versteht es perfekt die wahre Sex zu
verkaufen doch diese schillernde
rotlichtkarriere endet im Herbst 1957
Rosemarie Nitribitt wird am 1 november
tot in ihrer Wohnung aufgefunden nachdem
ihre Putzfrau die Polizei gerufen hat
Erna Krüger so heißt die Putzfrau und
Vertraute von Rosemarie Nitribitt sie
wird skeptisch nachdem sie einige Tage
nichts von Rosemarie gehört hat einer
Krüger fährt zur Wohnung und macht sich
dann erst recht Sorgen als sie sieht
dass sich vor der Wohnung Brötchen töten
befinden die unberührt da liegen
durch die verschlossene Tür hört sie das
Jaulen von Rosemaries Hund und ruft die
Polizei als diese dann kommt die Tür
öffnen lässt und die Wohnung betritt
finden sie die Leiche der
edelprostituierten
sie muss schon eine Weile dort liegen
denn Rosemaries Überreste sind bereits
stark verwest es gibt viele Unklarheiten
über den Tat Zeitpunkt aber zum Tat
Ablauf gibt es schon gesicherte
Erkenntnisse nimm uns mal bitte mit in
das Wohnzimmer von Rosemarie in der
trippert was weiß man über die Tat naja
wir wissen das Rosemarie nitri Bild von
einem Unbekannten Besucher zunächst
niedergeschlagen wird sie hat eine
Platzwunde am Kopf die stark blutet aber
Rosemarie ist weiter bei Bewusstsein sie
greift nach ihrem Telefon um Hilfe zu
rufen doch der Täter kommt ihr zuvor
reißt sie zu Boden legt seine Hände um
ihren Hals und erwürgt sie brutal dieser
Kampf dauert wohl mehrere Minuten
Rosemarie wehrt sich heftig hat aber am
Ende keine Chance
die Ermittler vermuten dass der Täter im
Affekt gehandelt hat und den Mord nicht
von vornherein geplant hat als er die
Wohnung betreten hat
anscheinend gibt es einen Streit der
eskaliert der Täter explodiert und tötet
Frankfurt bekannteste Edelhure
Rosemarie Nitribitt liegt tot auf dem
Boden eines ihrer Beine liegt auf dem
Sofa das andere darunter ihr Kopf ist
blutverschmiert ein frotte-tuch liegt
auf dem Boden daneben ein ebenfalls
blutverschmierte Telefonhörer und ein
zerbrochener Aschenbecher
auch bis heute weiß man nicht an welchem
Tag genau Rosemarie Nitribitt ermordet
worden ist ihre Leiche wird am 1
November 1957 gefunden die Polizei liegt
in 29 oktober als Todestag fest aber so
ganz genau weiß man das bis heute nicht
denn der Todeszeitpunkt hat sich nicht
genauer bestimmen lassen Grund dafür ist
mitunter massives polizeiversagen die
Polizei begeht eklatante
Ermittlungsfehler als die beiden
herbeigerufenen Polizisten in die
Wohnung eintreten schlägt Ihnen ein
beißender Gestank und Hitze entgegen es
ist der Gestank von Verwesung und die
Heizung ist voll aufgedreht die beiden
Beamten reißen das Fenster im Wohnzimmer
auf vom frische Luft hereinzulassen und
das ist ein folgenschwerer Fehler denn
die Temperatur am Tatort ist zu diesem
Zeitpunkt noch nicht gemessen und so
können die Ermittler keinen exakten
Todeszeitpunkt feststellen und wer nicht
weiß wann genau eine Tat passiert ist
der kann auch nicht herausfinden ob
mögliche Täter ein Alibi für den
fraglichen Zeitraum haben oder nicht und
das ist ja nicht die einzige Panne bei
den Ermittlungen
Rosemarie nitribits Tod verbreitet sich
unter dem Polizisten Frankfurt wie ein
Lauffeuer ebenso bei den Journalisten
der Stadt schließlich weiß jeder wer sie
ist und in welchem Gewerbe Sie tätig ist
und so stehen nach kurzer Zeit 26
Personen in der Wohnung die sich am
Tatort frei bewegen können meine seriöse
Spurensicherung ist so absolut unmöglich
26 Personen am Tatort also da muss man
keinen Experte sein um zu wissen das
geht gar nicht wenn wir das mal zu heute
vergleichen wie wäre es wenn
Journalisten einfach so an einen Tatort
dürfen Fotos machen rumlaufen also das
ist unvorstellbar
aber die Leute vor Ort durften sich
nicht nur alles angucken es wurde wie
damals auch üblich kräftig geraucht die
Asche fällt auf dem Boden herumlaufende
Journalisten hinterlassen ihre Fuß- und
Fingerabdrücke also ich bin keine
Forensikerin aber auch mir stellen sich
da die Nackenhaare auf ich will am
liebsten nur die Hände über den Kopf
zusammenschlagen ja und die Polizei hat
das alles zugelassen die zuständigen
Beamten sind überfordert und
wahrscheinlich sind sie auch deswegen
nachlässig und das hat die Ermittlung
nachhaltig beeinträchtigt und durch die
unklare Spurenlage ist der Kreis der
Verdächtigen gewaltig groß als Täter
kommt theoretisch jeder freier von
Rosemarie niedrigen Frage und davon gibt
es viele allein in einem Kalender den
sie geführt hat und der in der Wohnung
gefunden wird stehen über 60 Namen
außerdem finden die Beamten zahlreiche
Fotos von nitribits Kunden deren
Identitäten zum Teil erst ermittelt
werden müssen
Spuren gibt es also reichlich ein
gefundenes Fressen für die Presse die
Spekulationen und auch die
Ermittlungspannen überschlagen sich
es ist wirklich unglaublich Akten
verschwinden und Fotos auf den
prominente Männer an der Seite von
Rosemarie nittrebe zu sehen sind die
pressespe spekuliert damals sogar dass
die Polizei vieles vertuschen oder
zumindest unter den Tisch fallen lassen
will um die mächtigen zu schützen ja und
natürlich wird dem Promis ganz schnell
klar oh hier muss sich gar keiner Sorgen
machen die Öffentlichkeit bekommt nichts
mit wir werden hier nicht bloßgestellt
und der industrielle Harald von Polen
genießt sogar eine Sonderbehandlung er
darf das Polizeipräsidium zum Friseur
ganz unauffällig durch den Hintereingang
betreten ohne dass die vorne warten eine
Presse etwas davon mitbekommt die
Beamten ermitteln auch gegen Harald
Quandt gegen Ernst Sachs und dessen
Bruder Gunter Sachs doch am Ende sitzt
kein freier von rosemarine tripet auf
der Anklagebank sondern ein Vertrauter
von ihr mit dem sie keinen Sex hatte und
dieser vertraute heißt Heinz Pohlmann er
und Putzfrau Erna Krüger kennen die
niedrigen am besten
für Rosemarie erledigt der
verschiedenste Aufträge er kümmert sich
ums Auto geht mit dem Hund raus und er
ist ihr Schutz vor unangenehmen freien
wenn Rosemarie Nitribitt einen Kunden
nicht kennt dann ist es Heinz Pohlmann
der in der Küche aufpasst dass ihr
nebenan im Schlafzimmer nichts passiert
und Pohlmann hat die letzte Mahlzeit
gekocht die niedrige wird vor ihrem Tod
gegessen hat Reisbrei Pohlmann ist ihr
näher als viele andere das allein aber
macht ihn noch nicht zum
Hauptverdächtigen es gibt da noch andere
Gründe Heinz Pohlmann ist ein mehrfach
vorbestrafter Mann ein verurteilter
Kriegs Plünderer ein Urkundenfälscher
und Betrüger und er hat ständig Geld
Probleme so muss er seinem Arbeitgeber
schnell einen hohen Geldbetrag
zurückzahlen um nicht wegen
Unterschlagung bestraft zu werden
verdächtigerweise verfügt Pohlmann kurz
nach dem Tod von Rosemarie Nitribitt
über große Mengen Bargeld seine Schulden
in Höhe von 20.000 Mark zahlt er zurück
dabei hatte zuvor kaum seine kleinsten
Rechnungen bezahlen können den
Ermittlern kommt dies verdächtig vor und
es kommt zur Anklage Heinz Pohlmann
steht wegen Mordverdachts vor Gericht
klingt ja auch naheliegend Heinz
Pohlmann weiß dass ich in Rosemaries
Wohnung immer äußerst viel Bargeld
befindet und es ist natürlich sehr
verdächtig dass er kurz nach ihrem Tod
so viel Geld zur Verfügung hat also
richtig schlau kann der auch nicht sein
also Heinz Pohlmann wird angeklagt er
sitzt 10 Monate lang in
Untersuchungshaft aber kommt am Ende
dann doch frei ja das ist richtig denn
es heißt in dubio pro reo im Zweifel für
den Angeklagten das Schwurgericht
spricht Heinz Pohlmann im Juli 1960
knapp drei Jahre nach dem Mord frei aus
Mangel an Beweisen damit endet der Fall
die tribit er bleibt bis heute ungelöst
also Mirko was da alles schief gegangen
ist es doch echt unglaublich ich meine
was war denn das für eine Polizeiarbeit
niemand hat etwas so richtig mitbekommen
dann weiß man auch nicht ob da
vielleicht nicht auch doch noch mal hohe
Summen geflossen sind ja das waren
immerhin alles einflussreiche Leute und
dann Spuren wir jetzt noch mal zurück
als sie elf Jahre alt war wurde sie
vergewaltigt alle wussten wer es war
keiner wurde zur Rechenschaft gezogen
und jetzt wird sie auf eine ähnliche Art
und Weise aus dem Leben gerissen ja
jemand tut ihr das wirklich aller
schlimmste an ermordet sie und es wird
wieder irgendwie vertuscht und es ist
nicht ganz klar wer ist es denn jetzt
nun gewesen also ich finde das sehr sehr
tragisch ja Natalie da hast du
vollkommen Rechte sein wirklich sehr
trauriges Ende einer sehr schillernden
und tragischen Figur der die Rosemarie
niedrigt war immerhin eine Frau die
genau wusste was sie will die sich mutig
und selbstbewusst aber quasi schutzlos
in den selbstbestimmtes Leben gestürzt
hat
ich finde es unglaublich wie aus dem
einsamen vergewaltigten Mädchen eine so
taffe und wohlhabende Frau geworden ist
der Weg den sie damals gewählt hat mag
gesellschaftlich nicht akzeptiert worden
sein und trotzdem wurden ihre Dienste
von denselben Männern genutzt die nach
außen hin die Lebensweise von Rosemarie
Verurteilten
Rosemarie war ihr eigener Chef und das
war auch ein Risiko ein Risiko dass sie
am Ende leider das Leben gekostet hat es
heißt ja nicht umsonst prostitution ist
das älteste Gewerbe der Welt in der
deutschen Nachkriegszeit nach außen hin
verurteilt und doch nicht weniger
beliebt als zu jeder anderen Zeit auch
heutzutage ist es völlig legal diesen
Beruf nachzugehen
es gibt natürlich auch heute noch eine
Menge Schwierigkeiten und Unsicherheiten
in diesem Gewerbe aber das eine
Edelprostituierte so völlig schutzlos
ist so auf sich allein gestellt und am
Ende bei den Ermittlungen so viele
Fehler passieren das kommt hoffentlich
nicht mehr vor Sex macht Mord der Fall
der Rosemarie niedrigt bleibt ungelöst
aber nicht ungehört uns hat er nicht
mehr losgelassen Liebe Podcast
Hörerinnen und Hörer wir würden uns
freuen wenn ihr auch bei der nächsten
Folge wieder mit dabei seid bei Tatort
Deutschland Spezial euer Mirko und eure
Natalie die tragische Geschichte von
Rosemarie Nitribitt erzählen wir mit
Material der gemeinnützigen Initiative
rheinische Geschichte Artikeln der
Bild-Zeitung der Welt und dem Artikel
auf Rosemaries Spuren in der Frankfurter
Rundschau Redaktion Stefan Netzeband und
Antonia Haier Produktion serdarinis